EVICTIONS ARE EXPECTED TO
INCREASE.
THE CDC MORATORIUM EXPIRED
SATURDAY.
EXPERTS SAY ONE OF THE WORST
THINGS A TENANT CAN DO IS IGNORE
AN EVICTION NOTICE.
THE I-TEAM'S VANESSA MURPHY
IS LIVE IN DOWNTOWN LAS VEGAS
OUTSIDE THE REGIONAL JUSTICE
CENTER WITH MORE ON THE HELP
AVAILABLE FOR TENANTS FACING
EVICTION.
((VANESSA MURPHY))
THIS IS THE FIRST BUSINESS DAY
SINCE THE MORATORIUM ON EVICTION
HAS ENDED....
MORE EVICTION NOTICES ARE
EXPECTED TO BE DELIVERED AND
EVEN LOCK OUTS CAN BEGIN TODAY
DURING THE MORATORIUM.....
THE SELF HELP CENTER HERE IS
WHERE TENANTS AND LANDLORDS CAN
GO FOR HELP.
((WHAT YOU FILED
TODAY, IT'S GOING TO PAUSE IT.))
((TECHNICALLY, THEY
CAN COME OUT ON THE FOURTH TO
LOCK THE DOORS.))
((I THINK TOMORROW
YOU'LL KNOW FOR SURE.))
((VANESSA MURPHY))
THE CIVIL LAW SELF HELP CENTER
AT THE REGIONAL JUSTICE CENTER
IS ANTICIPATING SUCH AN UPTICK
IN EVICTIONS, STAFF AND SPACE
HAVE BEEN ADDED.
((LAUREN
PENA/DIRECTING ATTORNEY: THERE
ARE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE OUT
THERE WHO ARE JUST REALLY
WORRIED ABOUT HOW THEY ARE GOING
TO MAKE UP FOR PAST DUE RENT AND
WHERE THEY ARE GOING TO LIVE AND
I WOULD CALL THAT A CRISIS.))
((VANESSA MURPHY))
LAUREN PENA IS THE DIRECTING
ATTORNEY.
((PENA: IN NEVADA, WE
HAVE WHAT'S CALLED THE SUMMARY
EVICTION PROCESS WHICH IS ONE OF
THE FASTEST IN THE COUNTRY.
SO IT IS RAPID FIRE, LIGHTNING
SPEED.))
((VANESSA MURPHY))
SHE SAYS TENANTS WITH AN
EVICTION NOTICE SHOULD FILE AN
ANSWER WITH THE COURT WITHIN
SEVEN BUSINESS DAYS, APPLY FOR
RENTAL ASSISTANCE AND CHOOSE
MEDIATION.
((PENA: IF YOU DON'T DO
THAT, THAT EIGHTH DAY YOU COULD
GET LOCKED OUT.))
((VANESSA MURPHY))
THE LEGAL AID CENTER OF
SOUTHERN NEVADA WHICH OVERSEES
THE HELP CENTER, REPORTS
A TYPICAL MONTH....
IN JUNE, THAT NUMBER JUMPED TO
7-THOUSAND.
NOW THAT THE CDC EVICTION
MORATORIUM EXPIRED SATURDAY,
ANOTHER INCREASE IS EXPECTED.
((TOMMIE
WESLEY/TENANT: I DONE BEEN
WORKING, I DONE PAYING
EVERYTHING AND I F'IN TO BE
BASICALLY OUT.))
((VANESSA MURPHY))
TOMMIE WESLEY TELLS THE I-TEAM
HIS RENT JUMPED FROM 575 A MONTH
TO 850...
PORTAL...
HE SAYS HE JUST DOESN'T HAVE THE
MONEY.....
HE HASN'T RECEIVED AN
EVICTION NOTICE YET, BUT HE'S
WORRIED HE WILL AND HE'S HERE
LEARNING ABOUT HIS OPTIONS.
((TOMMIE: I'VE NEVER
BEEN THROUGH ANYTHING LIKE THIS
BEFORE SO I DON'T KNOW HOW IT'LL
GO.
HOPEFULLY IT'LL GIVE ME A LITTLE
TIME TO TRY TO FIGURE SOMETHING
OUT...))
((VANESSA MURPHY)
I TALKED WITH THE MANAGER OF THE
COMPANY HANDLING
TOMMIE'S PROPERTY...
HE TELLS ME YES, THE RENT WENT
UP....
NOTICES WENT OUT IN JUNE....AND
THAT COSTS HAVE GONE UP FOR
LANDLORDS...
HE ALSO TELLS ME IF TENANTS LIKE
TOMMIE REACH OUT AND ARE WILLING
TO WORK TOGETHER, THEY MAY OFFER
THE TENANTS AN EXTRA MONTH AT
THE PREVIOUS RATE...
WE HAVE LINKS AT 8 NEWS NOW WITH
RESOURCES....
REPORTING LIVE, VANESSA MURPHY,
8 NEWS NOW.//
((DENISE VALDEZ))
NEW AT 5.
PLANS FOR A PERMANENT 1
OCTOBER MEMORIAL ARE BEGINING TO